eux ils avaent leur coupables pour eux
on était les coupables vidéo des petits
polonais qui sont fait adopté il y en a
un qui boit l'autre il a fait une
connerie 10 ans avant c'est bon ça peut
pas être quelqu'un d'autre donc en gros
ils ont pas cherché
[Applaudissements]
àen 15 juillet 2010 c'est une chaude
journée d'été qui s'annonce à Saint
galmiier un petit village paisible non
loin de
Saint-Étienne ce jour-là une voiture se
garde dans la cour de la ferme de la
famille Toinon située un peu en retrait
du
village aux alentours de 9h une femme
qui se prennomme marie Jeanne arrive
chez sa copine Annie Toinon pour lui
déposer des haricots
elle rentre en bas dans la salle
principale et elle voit qu'il y a
personne donc elle appelle elle appelle
son amie
Annie bizarre personne répond et ce
n'est pas dans les habitudes d'Anny
toanon de rester coucher jusqu'à 9h du
matin alors son ami monte à
l'étage peut-être Annie a-t-elle besoin
d'aide elle monte les escaliers et la
première chambre c'est celle de Madame
anitoanon et là elle elle voit que la
porte est ouverte
découvre l'horreur l'horreur absolue il
y a du sang partout
sur son lit dans une Mar de sang
elle va immédiatement redescendre les
escaliers en hurlant et se rendre au
village à saintgalmier mariejanne
totalement paniqué se précipite sur la
première voiture vue et c'est une
ambulance elle leur explique la
situation elle monte dans
l'ambulance elle va guider ces deux
personnes jusqu'à jusqu'à la maison ces
de personnes vont pénétrer ell aussi
dans la maison découvrir la chambre et
le corps d'anitoinon s'approcher du
corps pour vérifier si elle est en vie
ou pas en vie elles vont prendre le pou
d'anitoon le pou ne répond plus elle est
morte aussitôt les ambulanciers
appellent les secours qui très vite
arrive sur
place il imagine un suicide par par
fusil de chasse tellement elle a la tête
massacrée voilà et puis il se rendent
compte qu'il y a pas de fusil tous les
cas il voit que c'est un homicide de
toute évidence anit toanon cette mère de
famille de 58 ans a été
[Musique]
assassinée c'est la section de recherche
de la gendarmerie de Lyon qui est en
charge de
l'enquête dans la chambre les enquêteurs
découvrent l'incroyable violence de ce
crime murs et plafonds sont couverts de
projections de
sang la victime est recouverte d'une
couette elle est en chemise de nuit
son visage est
méconnaissable madame Toinon n'a plus de
n'a plus de visage elle a vraiment le
crâne a été complètement défoncé elle a
reçu des coups à travers le visage d'une
violence inouie j'en veux pour preuve
que des dents on sauté qu'on retrouve
des dents sous le
crâne il y a une marque au niveau du
coup qui est une marque de compression
qui n'est pas une marque de
strangulation mais qui laisse penser que
quelqu'un la maintenait à ce niveaau et
violence des coups ne s'arrête pas au
visage de la
victime le bras gauche est dans le
plâtre et quand on va la retrouver dans
son lit son plâtre a glissé ça peut
vouloir dire qu'elle a aussi cherché à
se protéger avec son plâtre l'autre main
va être découverte avec des doigts très
fracturés et un doigt ne tenant plus que
par un lambeau de peau à la main de
toute évidence anit toanon a tenté de se
défendre en 20ain
alors qui pouvait bien en vouloir à la
victime au point de lui infliger de
telles
blessures un indice retrouvé sur la
scène de crime devrait faire avancer
l'enquête on va retrouver dans la main
droite des cheveux dont on pourra penser
qu'il s'agirait des cheveux de
l'agresseur qu'elle aurait arraché en
tentant de se
débattre une mèche blonde longue de
quelques
centimètres les cheveux sont souscell
pour être
analysé s'il s'agit bien de ceux de
l'agresseur la découverte est
capitale dans la chambre il y a un autre
indice prélevé par les
gendarmes une empreinte digitale sur la
poignée de la
porte en inspectant les lieux les
enquêteurs déduisent très vite que la
maison de la victime a été fouillée le
désordre qui règne ici ne laisse pas de
place au
des et puis il y a un élément qui vient
conforter la thèse d'un cambriolage le
sac à main d'anit toanon est
introuvable à l'intérieur
elle y avait placé près de 1000 € la
recette des ventes au marché des
produits de la
ferme s'agit-il d'un cambriolage qui a
mal tourné ou l'affaire est-elle plus
complexe
les enquêteurs décident de ratisser
méthodiquement les abords de la ferme à
la recherche du moindre élément
susceptible de les orienter en
20 et ils vont jouer de malchance car il
leur manque un élément crucial l'heure
exacte de la mort
d'anitanon et pour cause les gendarmes
choses incroyabl interdit au médecin
légiste de pénétrer sur la scène de
crime le médecin légiste arrive il me
semble à vers 101h donc juste après la
découverte du corps mais on lui interdit
l'accès on lui dit clairement que voilà
personne n'a accès à la scène de crime
qu'il faudra qu'il revienne plus tard
pour une prise de température du corps
il ne pourra avoir accès au corps qu'à
partir de 19h et c'est à 19h qu'il va
avoir un relevé de température soit 10h
après la découverte du corps de madame
anitoan c'est la première fois de ma vie
que j'entends un médecin légiste qui ne
peut
pas prendre la température du cadavre
pour faire son boulot et je me dis on
part mal quand même un retard
inexplicable dans les constatations
médico-légales qui aura des conséquences
dramatique sur la suite de
l'enquête les gendarmes poursuivent
leurs investigation autour du corps
d'anit toanon et ils vont faire une
étrange découverte au moment où le
cadavre est emmené à l'Institut médicau
[Musique]
légal on va découvrir sous la CU d'on
une barre de fer assez longue un outil
agricole on imagine que c'est un outil
de défense de la victime qu'elle dormait
avec ça au cas où elle aurait été
agressée donc elle avait ça sous la
main se sentait-elle menacée pour dormir
ainsi avec une barre de fer dans son
lit
pour le savoir les enquêteurs décident
d'interroger le mari de la
victime il est 11h du matin ce 14
juillet
2010 lorsque Bernard Toinon agriculteur
de 56 ans reçoit un appel sur son
portable on va lui indiquer
effectivement que son épouse est
décédée depuis l'aube bernardanon
travaille sur ses terres à 10 minutes de
chez et lui les gendarmes lui demandent
de venir les rejoindre
immédiatement arrivé à son domicile il
va se passer deux choses il va découvrir
d'abord les services ambulancés les
services de santé qui sont là les
gendarmes qui vont être là et il va être
empêché de rentrer dans le dans la
maison le père de famille parvient à
joindre deux de ses enfants Adeline 26
ans et Aurélien 25
ans j' effondré comm dis quand je suis
rentré chez ma sœur pour la informé
j'étais en larme quand j'ai appelé la
secrétaire de mon travail pour dire que
je venais pas j'étais en larme voilà
quoi j'étais sur le choc Johan le cadet
de 22 ans travaille sur un chantier il
est prévenu par les gendarmes en milieu
des
journ bah sur coup j'étais choqué
et après fait je pas
trop pas il vous ont Ren ditutre non cou
pour tous c'est
l'incompréhension car en apparence rien
laiss présager qu'un tel drame puisse
[Musique]
arriver éta
agricultri
tous deux exploit la ferme
familiale le couple avait qu enfants
y Adeline Aurélien
etan était une femme plutôt discrète
mais très apprécié dans le
village bien les G March par à tout le
monde ma mère cétait une bonne paysane
quoi don tout ce soit visuellement
parlant dans tout à la section de
recherche de Lyon le soir du drame les
gendarmes envisage plusieurs hypothèses
la première c'est l'hypothèse d'un
rudeur dans la région il y a pas de
délinquence ou quasiment pas de
délinquence il y a pas de il y a pas de
vol pu c'est pas une ferme de riche hein
c'est pas il y a pas une roll garé dans
la cour la deuxième piste c'est la piste
du règlement de compte mais bon la
personnalité de la victime une
agricultrice qui s'occupe de la maison
ferme qui vend des ufs sur le marché à
Saint-Galmier ça correspond pas non
plus à du grand banditisme et un
règlement de compte et puis il y a la
thèse
intrafamiliale alors c'est l'ensemble de
la famille Toinon qui est entendu à la
gendarmerie de Saint-Galmier dans des
pièces
séparées où était-il que faisait-il
avant 9h ce matin du 15 juillet et ce
sont le père de famille Bernard et son
cadet
qui concentre toute l'attention car tous
les deux habitaent à la ferme avec Annie
et voici ce que Bernard
déclare ce matinl je me suis levé à 5h30
avant de descendre je suis allé voir la
chambre de mon épouse j'ai poussé la
porte j'ai vu que ma femme dormait j'ai
refermé la porte je suis descendu au
rez-de-chaussée ensuite je suis parti
directement sur mon
exploitation il rejoint son exploitation
agricole il a des repères très précis
c'est systématiquement avant 6h parce
qu'il n'entend jamais le flash info à la
radio de
6h à 7h30 Bernard Toan explique avoir
reçu la visite d'un vétérinaire pour un
examen sur l'une de ses
génise après le père c'est Johann le
petit dernier le seul des quatre enfants
à encore vivre chez ses parents qui est
interrogé
ce matinl il s'est levé à 6h50 et n'a
absolument rien remarqué
[Musique]
d'étrange je vers
7 7h ça
dépend près5es
chantier travailler chantier j'ai travé
comme t les
jouran est donc persuadé que sa mère
dormait lorsqu'il est parti
travailler
[Musique]
les auditions des membres de la famille
Toan n'apportent rien tous ont l'air de
bonne
[Musique]
foi cependant comme il est d'usage dans
ce genre d'enquête le père et les qure
enfants doivent se soumettre à une série
de
prélèvements le soir même il les
prélèvement sous les ongles qui sont fa
mes vêtements du jour ont été
réquisitionnés le voit seront auscultés
inspectés par les militaires de la
gendarmerie on passera du BLU star pour
savoir s'il y a pas des trace de sang
sur les pédales sur le pomau de levier
de vitesse sur le volant et
cetera et on gratte également sous leurs
ongles afin de voir si on retrouve des
particules ADN appartement à la
victime les auditions sont terminées et
toute la famille Toinon quitte la
gendarmerie lorsqu'une scène surréaliste
va se produire
Bernard le père s'approche de ses
enfants et lance cette phrase pour le
moins sibiline j'espère que c'est pas un
de vous qure et moi je lu répondu
j'espère que c'est pas toi cette
remarque du père provoque un énorme
malaise chez les enfants toin et pour
cause l'histoire de cette famille n'est
pas banale une famille qui en réalité
cache de bien lourd
secret pour comprendre il faut remonter
20 ans en arrière au début des années 90
annieanon découvre qu'elle est stérile
et qu'elle ne peut donc pas avoir
d'enfant alors le couple engage une
procédure d'adoption qui aboutira en
1993 il vont partir en Pologne pour
adopter deux
enfants proposé deux enfants deux petits
polonais un garçon et une fille yannique
11 ans et sa sœur Adeline 10 ans sont
alors sur le point d'être adopté par le
couple trouen
ils vont à l'orphelina et là il y a une
surprise de taille qui les attend
puisque finalement on leur explique que
c'est plus deux enfants qu'il va falloir
adopter mais quatre parce qu'il s'agit
d'une frattererie de qure enfants et
qu'il n'est pas question de les
séparer et ils vont
repartir avec les quatre enfants pour
les ramener donc à la ferme Annie et
Bernardon qui jusquà présent était sans
enfant se retrouve donc du jour au
lendemain à la d'une famille nombreuse
avec Yannick Adeline et leurs deux plus
jeunes frères Aurélien 9 ans et Johan 7
ans l'installation à la ferme de la
veillère se passe plutôt bien les
enfants apprennent vite à parler
français mais dans le petit village de
Saint galniier les quatre petits
polonais sont très vite victimes du
racisme Milant on é un petit peu mis à
part à l'école par c'est vrai qu'on
était les cas petit étranger qui
arrivaient à l'école donc forcément sal
Polaque sal polonire t dans ton pays
tuas rien à faire là et c'est pour
Johann et Aurélien les deux petits
derniers que l'intégration est
particulièrement
difficile d'autant que le réconfort ce
n'est pas auprès de leur mère qu'il le
trouent bien au contraire Annie
n'hésitait pas à s'en prendre aux
enfants car en fait derrière l'image
toujours souriante de cette maman annie
est une femme
alcoolique ah quand elle buvait pas cé
une femme adorable généreuse gentil
toujours prête à à rendre servicere elle
est infernale agressive méchante et
insultante à la fois à tel point que
parfoison pouvait dire des choses
effroyables à ses enfants j'ai adopté de
enfants et pas qu ça l' toujours dit B
au début on prenait assz mal c'est quand
même choquant puis bon à la suite
c'était la routine habituelle on s était
habitué à ce genre de réflexion on y
faisait même plus
attention les insultes fuse
particulièrement à destination de Johann
le benjamin qui au fil du temps devient
le souffre douleur de sa maman
elle lui versait de l'eau dans son lit
pour dire à tout le monde comme quoi il
faisait pipi au lit il en pleurait il
m'appelait en larme il voulait suicider
il en avait marre à bout Johann sombre
des choses incroyables à à peine 13 ans
il se réfugie dans
l'alcool j'ai toujours bu en fait
toujours petite quantité mais chez moi c
courant sur la table la bouteille
de petit on m de dans le ver puis une
plus grosse goutte lorsque les choses
deviennent trop difficiles pour lui et
ça les experts lui disent il f et une
des fes c'est l'alcool et l'autre fuite
c'est su c'est la mort et donc il a fait
plusieurs tentatives de
suicide alcoolique suicidaire Johan
aurait-il voulu se venger des
persécutions de sa mère son frère
Aurélien lui aussi maltraité l'aurait-il
aidé les gendarmes commencent
sérieusement à se poser la
question dè le lendemain du drame les
enquêteurs interrogent l'entourage de la
famille Toinon et notamment une voisine
et ce qu'elle va dire va s'avérer
capital pour
l'enquête certains proches voisins amis
à l'annonce du décès et des conditions
du décès de Dan Toinon immédiatement ces
gensl vont dire c'est Aurélien Joan ça
peut pas être autrement ça devait
arriver à saintgalmier les rumeurs vont
bon train cette fois cela concerne
Aurélien pour les habitants du village
il serait responsable 10 ans ôt de la
mort de son grand-père l'ffet remonte à
l'année
2000 à cette époque le père Danis Toinon
vivait à la ferme familiale et les
choses se passaient très mal avec ses
quatre
petitsenfants on n pas eu de très bonnes
relations avec lui il était
alcoolique puis même non alcoolisé il
est assez violent toujours des insultes
juif sale Polaque sale Boch le vieil
homme aurait même très souvent menacé
ses petits enfants avec son fusil de
chasse son gros pistolet du MO son sa
carabine le 12 quoi qui mettait les deux
cartouches dedans il le mett entre les
gens vu qu'il était dans un fauteuil
roulant et il nous cour après il nous
disait un coup de 12 que se débarrasse
sale poac sale et un soir de novembre
2000 Aurélien n'aurait plus supporté les
menaces incessante du grand-père à
l'époque j'étais âgé de 15 ans on était
allé à une fête de belgardon for je suis
rentré j'étais fortement
alcoolisé j'ai balancer un téléviseur
dans la
tê le grand-père est gravement blessé au
crâne Aurélien lui vole alors une forte
somme d'argent avant de s'enfuir ivre au
volant de la voiture de son père le
grand-père est mort un mois plus tard
euh d'une grise
cardiaque dans le village vous imaginez
bien que les rumeurs ont largement
dépassé la réalité donc du coup c'était
le gamin qui avait tué son
grand-père c'est l'épisode qui est resté
dans la mémoire des des gens de
saintgalmier et qui sûrement a fait que
les gendarmes se sont tout de suite
intéressés à au de garçons notamment
Aurélien quoi 10 ans après les faits les
conditions de l'agression du grand-père
rappelle étonnamment aux enquêteurs les
conditions du meurtre
d'Anon et les gendarmes vont bientôt
réunir d'autres éléments à l'encontre
d'Ur car une autre histoire arrive vite
aux oreilles des enquêteurs c'est celle
de la v e de la ferme familiale Aurélien
qui est le seul agriculteur de la fratie
se porte acreur c'est en 2008 et j'avais
envisagé de reprendre l'exploitation
familiale seulement Bernard et sa femme
choisiront l'offre plus alléchante d'un
autre
acheteur et du coup j'avais coupé les
ponts avec eu pendant un an et
dem d'année 2009 pour les fêtes de fin
d'année j'avais relouer les liens avec
eux réconcilié Aurélien en voulait-il
encore à ses parents cette brouille
constituerait-elle un mobile les
gendarmes commencent à l'envisager
sérieusement reste à trouver un élément
matériel une preuve de
culpabilité les enquêteurs concentrent
leurs efforts sur la recherche de l'arme
du crime
sans savoir qu'ils l'ont déjà en leur
possession l'autopsie permet d'établir
la forme de l'arme du CRIM on sait que
c'est un objet contendant à rayure très
probant métallique et du coup on pense
on repense à cette fameuse barre de fer
qu'on a retrouvé dans le
lit et lorsqu'elle est présenté au
médecin légiste il dit oui évidemment
c'est ça alors les emprintes des deux
plus jeunes enfants de la famille toanon
Aurélien et Johan se trouvent-ell sur
cette barre de fer l'arme est analysée
en
urgence et on ne retrouve ni l'ADN
d'Aurélien Toinon ni l'ADN de Joan
Toinon sur cette barre mais surprises il
y a bien un ADN sur
l'arme c'est celui du père de
famille pour l'avocat de Bernard toanon
la présence d'ADN sur l'arme ne permet
pas pas d'accuser son client car cette
barre de fer est un objet familier de la
ferme des toinons le père de famille a
très bien plus la manipuler avant le
crime du matériel comme cela il y en a
dans son exploitation plusieurs et
lorsque les services enquêteurs ont
perquisitionné l'exploitation ils en ont
retrouvé donc ça ne posose pas l'ombre
d'une difficulté le fait queil les
empprints Deon il a jamais dit c'est pas
possible deuxè élément il faut savoir
que l'exploitation de on c'est une
exploitation qui est ouverte c'est dire
que n'importe quelle personne peut venir
récupérer un outil ce jour-là avant un
autre moment sur l'exploitation le
garder
l'emporter quant au prélèvement fait sur
les mains de Bernard Tanon le jour du
drame il n'y a ni trace de sang ni trace
de l'ADN d'an sous ces
ongles en revanche on retrouve un autre
ADN sur Bernard on retrouve sous les
ongles un ADN féminin mais qui n'est pas
ADN d' qui est un ADN inconnu donc on
peut imaginer qu'il a eu un contact
charnel avec une femme et lorsqu'il a
été interrogé sur ce point il dira qu'il
savait absolument qu'il voit pas du tout
de quoi il peut
s'agir à ces éléments le père de famille
est mis hors de cause par les
gendarmes reste l'empreinte
souvenez-vous découverte sur la poignée
de la
portefenêtre c'est celle de Johann le
petit
qui vit encore à la maison l'empreinte
digitale qui est sur la porte-fenêtre
elle appartient à Monsieur Johann Toinon
qui lui explique très simplement cette
empreinte en disant je m'occupais de ma
mère depuis qu'elle avait le bras cassé
pour ranger ses vêtements si elle avait
besoin d'ouvrir la fenêtre pour aérer
c'est moi qui le faisait pour fermer
c'était pareil et dans tous les cas je
vivais dans cette maison donc c'est tout
à fait normal que mes empreintes
digitales soient sur cette
porte-fenêtre finalement les expertises
scientifiques ne sont d'aucune aide pour
les
gendarmes cependant ils ont l'intime
conviction can a été tué par deux de ses
enfants Aurélien et
Johann les gendarmes ont acquis la
certitude absolue qu'il s'agit d'un
drame
intrafamilial leur cible c'est Johann et
Aurélien le 27 juillet 2010 soit 12
jours après le meurtre les gendarmes ont
une idée il décid de placer toute la
famille Toinon en garde à vue Bernard le
père Aurélien le bagarur Adeline la sœur
enceinte de 8 mois et Johann le petit
dernier l'objectif est de faire parler
l'un d'entre
eux on met tout le monde en garde à vue
pour forcer l'un d'entre eux à craquer
et soit à avouer soit à désigner l'un
des deux garçons c'est très net il n'y a
strictement aucun élément matériel dans
le dossier à ce moment-là il est 6h du
matin lorsque la garde à vue
commence une épreuve qui s'annonce
difficile notamment pour le plus jeune
Johann 22 ans pour Joan c'est abominable
cette garde à vue c'est-à-dire qu'il est
placé en garde à vue à 6h le matin il va
immédiatement dire aux enquêteurs qu'il
n'a pas pris son traitement il a un
traitement relativement lourd
d'antidépresseur donc solithique qu'il
est pas bien face aux enquêteurs le
benjamin de la famille est donc
incapable de répondre aux question
pourtant les gendarmes vont le cuisiner
persuader qu'il couvre son grand frère
Aurélien ah ben ils me disaaient qu'
étaaiit sur CEN ils avaient les preuves
que au début il m'ont dit qu'ils avaient
retrouvé des poils dans la main de ma
mère si c'est pas ton frère c'est
obligatoirement toi donc dis que c'est
ton frère dis que c'est ton frère la
pression des gendarmes le benjamin
continue à tout implication dans le
meurtre de sa mère seulement le jeune
homme va commettre un impère Johan
faittat d'une conversation qu'il aurait
avec Aurélien quelques jours avant le
crime il va évoquer une phrase qui
aurait été prononcé c'est Aurélien qui
parle à Johan et qui dit tu t'occupes du
père je m'occupe de
laetteteritet d'une bombe et
la est passé entre les deux frères pour
assassiner les parents dans un seul but
[Musique]
hérité en réalité Johann devant notre
caméra explique qu'il ne s'agissait que
d'une
boutade parce que moi j'ai toujours une
passion pour les camping-car il m'a dit
pas que tu vas campingc tu t'occupes des
parents et l'héritage j'ai toujours
reconnu
ça c'était une blague de mauvais goût le
problème c'est que cette phrase conforte
les gendarmes dans l'idée qu'ils sont
sur la bonne
piste même si Aurélien continue de crier
son innocence ils m'ont mis la pression
mais non non j'ai jamais craqué non
qu'est-ce que vous dites pendant tout
votre garde ah bah jeny tout en bloc
comme depuis le
[Musique]
début les interrogatoires s'enchaînent
et vers 23h soit plus de 17h après le
début de la garde à vue coup de théâtre
Johann
craque à ce moment-là il va commencer à
accuser son frère en disant j'ai vu sa
voiture la première chose qu'il dit
c'est j'ai vu la voiture d'Aurélien ce
matinl bon je dit que c'était mon frère
je l'avais vu voici ce que Johann
raconte aux
gendarmes le matin du meurtre d'anit
wanon soit le 15 juillet vers 7h il
aurait entendu sa mère crier il se
serait alors précipité à la fenêtre et
aurait reconnu la voiture de son frère
Aurélien quittant la
ferme j'ai vu l'arrière du
véhicule il serait alors remonté et
aurait découvert sa mère morte dans son
lit il va expliqu avoir vu un certain
nombre de choses qui sont rigoureusement
conformes avec la scène de crime sur son
procès verbal d'audition Johann décrit
une quantité importante de sang dans la
chambre de sa mère et des projections
sur les murs il va même plus loin il
déclare que c'est lui qui a fermé les
rideaux puis de peur d'être accusé du
meurtre de sa mère Johan explique être
reparti sans rien dire à
personne dans la pièce d'interrogatoire
voisine face aux accusations de son
frère Aurélien lui ne Sée pas Aurélien
va apprendre que Joan l'accuse et
Aurélien va toujours re être constant en
disant mais ce n'est pas pas possible ce
n'est pas possible parce que je n'y
étais pas alors pour faire craquer
Aurélien les gendarmes vont jouer le
tout pour le tout au beau milieu de la
nuit il l'emmène voir sa sœur enceinte
de 8 mois épuisé par la garde à vue elle
dort dans un bureau ils m'ont présenté
dans la pièce où elle était allongée en
train de pleurer ils sont venus avec
oréen M Notter dans la salle il ils
m'ont pas lâché
hein donc tout ça pour pour me faire
craquer moi pour faire craquer mes
frères maintenant tu avoues sinon ta
sœur elle va aller accoucher en prison
elle ne verra pas grandir son enfant et
elle laiss sera incarcéré à la suite
alors tu nous dis que c'est toi et puis
on en reste là on en finit mais Aurélien
reste
muet alors les gendarmes vont trouver la
faille interrogé sur son emploi du temps
à l'heure du crime aurélien est
incapable de prouver ce qu'il faisait et
où il était au moment où son frère dit
avoir vu sa voiture soit un peu avant 7h
du
matin après plus de 36 he les deux plus
jeunes enfants de la famille Toinon sont
mis en examen pour assassinat et
complicité d'assassinat ils sont
incarcérés la prison quand je suis
rentré le 28 c'est pas le soir même que
j'ai réalisé c'est le lendemain matin au
réveil comm je dis on avait passé 48 ans
en garde à vue on était fatigué épuisé
c'est le lendemain matin au réveil j'ai
vraiment réalisé que j'étais en
prison moi qui a l'habitude d'être
toujours dehors
je retrouve enfermé dans une cellule de
9 m car 22h sur
24 pendant ma détention j'apprends qu'il
a eu les obsèques de ma mère je n'ai pas
eu le droit d'y participer je le V très
très mal je sais pas où je suis
quoi tout qui s écroulé
[Musique]
je
finir en apprenant la mise en cause et
l'incarcération de de de ses enfants
adoptifs Bernard Toinon accuse le choc
Bernardon vraiment va subir de plein
fouet le fait de se dire que peut-être
potentiellement ce sont deux de ces
enfants qui ont commis ce geste
atroce la Sée qu à elle ne cro pas un se
instant à la Culp de ses frères
moi je suis effondré parce que moi à ce
moment-là le 28 juillet ils m'ont tout
enlevé ils m'ont enlevé mon frère mon
meilleur ami mon confidant ils m'ont
tout enlevé ce jour-là donc frcément je
me suis retrouvé toute
seule les investigations se poursuivent
car les enquêteurs le savent en
l'absence de preuve matérielles leur
dossier n'est pas très solide il
s'intéressent alors à la mèche de
cheveux blonds retrouvé souvenez-vous
dans la main de la victime ses cheveux
appartiennent-ils à
Aurélien et à ce sujet la grande sœur
Adeline va leur raconter une scène
troublante quelques temps après le 15
juillet il y a une réunion de famille
dans avec les oncles et tantes et puis
Bernard et les enfants Toinon et l'une
des tentees va faire une réflexion lors
de cette de cette réunion de famille en
disant ah Aurélien il te manque des
cheveux
tu as un trou dans dans ta chevelure
anon aurait-elle arraché les cheveux de
son fils alors qu'elle se débattait les
gendarmes ont bien l'intention de le
découvrir seulement il y a quelque chose
qui ne colle pas il vont aussi chercher
à savoir quelle était la longueur des
cheveux d'Aurélien à ce momentlurélien a
les cheveux rasés donc on cherche à
savoir si 10 jours auparavant il pouvait
avoir les cheveux plus longs du coup ils
vont faire la tournée des coiffeurs pour
savoir si sa coupe de cheveux mais ces
recherches ne donnent rien seul les
analyses ADN pourront dire à qui
appartient cette mèche de cheveux et
quelques jours plus tard le résultat
surprend tout le monde en définitive les
cheveux qui sont dans la main
d'anitoinon savont être ceux d'anitoinon
donc on aura perdu beaucoup de temps sur
ces investigations
là les enquêteurs s'intéressent alors au
mobile évoqué en garde à vue par Johan
souvenez-vous ce pacte entre les deux
frères pour soi-disant hériter et
acheter un
camping-car alors ce projet d'achat
a-t-il vraiment
existé donc on va aller faire tous les
toutes les concession de camping-car du
coin et on va trouver une jeune fille
qui va expliquer qu'effectivement elle a
vu Johan dans le dans le magasin qui
venait regarder des des campinicars
lorsqu'on lui présente à la photo de
Joan Toinon et sa voiture il va dire ce
visage m'est familier il me dit quelque
chose elle dit pas je suis sûr de
l'avoir vu elle dit ce visage est
familier mais interrogé Johann n avoir
mis les pieds dans cette
concession même si par extraordinaire il
s'était rendu dans ce magasin ça ne
prouvait strictement rien c'était des
gamins de 20 ans qui de 19 ans 20 ans
qui avaient des envies de de de pour l'
d' pingc pour l'autre d'une caravane
pour pour se mettre autour d'un étan
donc qui avait envie d'argent et qui
aurait dit alors pour eux Seon sur le
temps de la plaisanterie mais pour les
enquêteurs de manière très sérieuse et
ben puisqu'il nous faut de l'argent il
faut qu'on qu'on rectifie les parents
voilà tous les éléments à charge tombent
les uns après les autres les cheveux ne
sont pas ceux d'Aurélien l'ADN des deux
frères n'est pas sur l'arme du crime le
mobile est
fragile alors pour tirer au clair cette
affaire le juge d'instruction décide
d'organiser une confrontation entre
Aurélien et
Johanne le 31 août 2010 les deux cadets
de la famille Toinon se retrouvent donc
face à face Johann accuse toujours son
frère du crime mais Aurélien va
l'interpeller je dis mais rends-toi
compte de ce que tu m'accuses pourquoi
comme je dis les gendarmes ils t'ont dit
qu'il y avait mes cheveux dans la main
c'est ce qu'il t'ont dit pour te faire
craquer et tout donc en présence de son
frère Aurélien va expliquer que ce ne
sont pas ses cheveux qui sont dans la
main de sa mère en apprenant de la
bouche d'Aurélien que les gendarmes lui
ont menti Johan va revenir sur ses
avis et voilà je me su dit c'est pas
possible de continuer à mentir comme ça
tout ça pour leur faire plaisir c'est
pour ça que là tout de suite après j'é
dé menti j'ai dit c'est pas
que tout ce que j' raconté CIT pas
vrai qu'il n'a jamais vu la voiture de
son frère qu'il n'y a jamais eu de
projet criminel et que s'il a menti
jusqu'à présent c'était sous pression
policière il va dire qu'en réalité il a
tout inventé qu'on lui a soufflé les
réponses et que de toute façon il n'a
jamais vu son frère ce jour-l il se
rétracte
complètement Johan a donc tout
inventé ce matinl est à 6h45 sur son
chantier comme ilavait affirmé au départ
et n'a rien remarqué d'anormal dans la
maison seulement il reste une question
qui pose problème comment Johann
savait-il qu'il y avait du sang sur les
murs et que les rideaux étaient tirés le
juge l'interroge à ce sujet et voici ce
qu'il répond j'avais vu la chambre de la
perquisition parce qu'en fait au début
il m'ont fait
monter ma chambre j' fer à la porte et
après m'avait rappelé il m'ont fait
remonter pour ça là la porte elle est
ouverte là mais vite fait je l'ai vu la
chambre je peux pas arrêter pour
regarder je suis monté comme ma porte
ouver j'ai just un coup d'œil et après
je suis parti dans ma chambre alors
Johan dit-il la
vérité quoi qu'il en soit les éléments à
charge contre les frères ça me
nu c'est un énorme soulagement on se dit
tiens quand même voilà
maintenant je vais peut-être pouvoir
sortir de prison et continuer à me
battre à l'extérieur pour autant le juge
va en décider autrement il maintient les
deux frères en détention car malgré
l'absence de preuve la justice à la
conviction corélien et Johann ont tué
ensemble leur
mère pire qu'ils ont prémédité leur
geste pour s'enrichir pour l'accusation
on est dans un scénario où ce jour-là
Aurélien serait venu au domicile
conjugal retrouver son frère et où ils
auraient été tous les deux présents sur
la scène de crime et tous les deux
présents au moment des coups mortels
Aurélien et Johan aurait attendu que
leur père Bernard quitte la ferme petit
matin puis ils auraient surpris leur
mère dans son sommeil il l'aurait frappé
avec une barre de fer ramassé sur
l'exploitation les coup sont d'une telle
violence que il n'est pas non plus on
peut pas écarter que la barre de fer a
été tenue à de mains donc par un seul
auteur ce qui impliquerait puisqu'on
sait qu'il y a des traces qui ont été
retrouvées au niveau du du coup de
Madame Toinon que un deuxième auteur la
maintienne et la plaque sur le matelas
pendant qu'elle est frappée par
quelqu'un qui pourrait tenir une barre
de fer à demain ensuite les frères
auraient pris soin de ne laisser aucune
trace sur l'arme du crime puis ils
auraient volé la recette du marché dans
le sac à main d'Anny pour faire croire à
un
cambriolage les deux fouillant après euh
éventuellement la maison pour trouver de
l'argent le départ premier d'Aurélien
qui n'a rien à faire à ce moment-là à
cette heure-là sur les lieux le départ
dans un second temps de Johan qui lui
est naturellement sur les lieux à ce
moment-là les deux frères seraient
enfuite parti travailler et auraiit fa
la surprise en apprenant le
drame eux ils avaient leur coupables
pour eux on était les coupables vidéo
des petits polonais qui sont fait adopté
il y en a un qui boit l'autre il a fait
une connerie 10 ans avant c'est bon ça
peut pas être quelqu'un
d'autre donc en gros ils ont pas cherché
ailleurs et puis surtout il y a le vide
à côté c'est-à-dire si c'est pas eux
c'est qui
quoi mais au sein de la famille Tanon de
nouvelles révélations vont bientôt faire
rebondir
l'enquête en juillet 2011 1 an presque
jour pour jour après le
meurtre Bernard toanon le mari d'an fait
une annonce à sa
fille je reçois un coup de fil de mon
père qui me dit oui j'ai un truc très
urgent à dire est-ce que ce serait
possible que quon se voit ce soir dit
bah oui bah viens à la maison viens
manger il a pas de souci et en fait
quand quand il est venu c'est là où il
m'a appris sa relation et là c'est la
douche froide de but en blanc Bernard
toanon avoue à sa fille entretenir une
liaison amoureuse et pas avec n'importe
qui car sa nouvelle amie n'est pas une
inconnue c'est la fille d'une voisine
c'est celle qui souvenez-vous a porté
des accusations à l'encontre de deux
frères cadet pour Adeline cette nouvelle
est un choc immense c'est pas possible
par avec elle quoi je dis ça serait
j'aurais peut-être mieux pris si c'était
quelqu'un d'étranger à la famille un
coup de foudre ça arrive à tout le monde
j'aurais peut-être mieux pris mais
sachant que c'éit cette personne là non
il a il a pas perdu son temps pour
refaire sa vie il a vite
oublié son épouse avec laquelle il a été
quand même marié pendant plus de 30 ans
pour tout le monde c'est la même
question Bernard le père de famille
avait-il une liaison au moment de la
mort de sa
femme pour Johan le fils c'est fort
possible en fait j'ai pas été étonné
parce que même moi je rigolais avec ma
mère je disais il va encore s'occuper
des oiseaux fa
attentionant seulement bernardanon
réfute totalement cette hypothèse il
affirme que cette idile avec la fille de
la voisine n'a débuté qu'après le
[Musique]
drame
alors l'ADN féminin retrouvé sous les
ongles de Bernard le 15 juillet 2010
serait-il celui de sa nouvelle compagne
si tel est le cas le père de famille
aurait donc menti et pourrait devenir
suspect lorsque les garmes on su qu'il
avait une relation intime et qu'il
n'arrivait pas à la
dater ils se sont empressés d'aller
prélever donc avoir son ADN pour le
comparer avec l'ADN retrouvé sous les
ongles de
Bernard ADN ne correspondent pas pour
les gendarmes la piste du père est
abandonnée mais pour une partie de la
famille il en est autrement j'ai des
doutes sur mon père parce que déjà àune
il a refait sa vie un an après donc
forcément ça fait poser beaucoup de
questions et puis ben l'aspect financier
surtout financièrement parlant c'est
quand même le jackpot pour lui
financièrement et puis ben surtout c'est
son ADN quoi c'est quelques minimes
allles sur l'arme du crime c'est quand
même le sien c'est pas celui de mes
frères donc moi en prenant tous les
détails je me dis il a quand même une
faille quelque
part les soupçons d'Adel au sujet de son
père vont aller
grandissant depuis le début de l'enquête
Bernard aurait tenté de la manipuler à
plusieurs reprises
Adeline aimerait bien avoir des
nouvelles de son frère aimerait bien
aller voir son frère en prison pour
essayer de de comprendre simplement ce
qui s'est passé et lorsqu'elle a
manifesté le désir de visiter ses
frères son père lui a dit que
juridiquement c'était impossible qu'elle
n'avait pas le droit de demander un
permis de visite qu'elle ne pouvait pas
communiquer avec ses frères
ensuite Bernard aurait dit à sa fille
qu'Aurélien avait avoué le meurtre et
que finalement son ADN aurait été
retrouvé sur l'arme du crime évidemment
tout cela est faux visiblement Bernard
aurait menti à sa fille quand on a vu
MRE 30 au tribunal il nous dit moi je
comprends toujours pas pourquoi aéen il
est en
détention et c'est là j'ai compris comme
quoi avait tout inventé Etel va
découvrir à cette occasion là qu'elle ne
connaît pas le dossier que ce qu'on a pu
lu lui raconter notamment son papa n'est
pas du tout le reflet du du dossier
alors Bernard aurait-il délibérément
menti à sa fille et si oui pour quelle
raison Bernard Toinon va indiquer
effectivement qu'il s'est trompé pas
qu'il a siamment communiqué des éléments
ou des déclarations totalement erroné
mais qu'il l'a mal interprété ou qu'il
s'est trompé sur ce que lui a rapporté
son avocat de l'époque ça va marquer une
rupture dans la famille puisque euh tous
vont changer d'avocat Bernard Tonon va
prendre son propre avocat Adeline Toinon
elle va également choisir son conseil de
manière à avoir un accès complet au
dossier et à pouvoir en voir la vraie
réalité convaincu de l'innocence de ses
deux frères Adeline toanon décide de
couper alors tous les ponts avec son
père au printemps 2012 après 23 mois de
détention Joan et Aurélien Tanon sont
libérés avec obligation de porter un
bracelet électronique dans l'attente de
leur
procès nous sommes le 7 février 2014
presque 4 ans après la mort
d'Anon le procès de ses deux plus jeunes
fils s'ouvre devant les assises de la
Loire à
Saint-Étienne Johan et Aurélien
comparaissent libr pour les deux frères
l'enjeu est énorme accusé d'un matricide
particulièrement violent ils enc la
prison à
[Musique]
vie on risque la perpétuité quand même
on se
[Musique]
dit merde on va peut-être passer 30 ans
pour un crime qu'on a pas commis ça fait
mal moi je partais
perdante pour moi ils étaient condamnés
donc moi j'étais partie perdante dès le
début même si les gens autour de moi me
dis mais non voir il vontre libr vont re
je disais je préfère partir perdante
comme ça Mo s' a une bonne nouvelle
c'est mieux je voulais pas je voulais
pas y penser ça me rend des
malade la salle est pleine beaucoup
d'habitants de saintgalmier sont venus
assister au procè à l'ouverture de ce de
ce procès à
Saint-Étienne il y avait une ambiance
très lourde il y a beaucoup de tension
évidemment il y a notamment le clan le
papa et son clan et les enfants et leur
clan aussi on est côte à côte mais on se
parle pas sans preuve irréfutable sans
témoin tient beaucoup sur la
personnalité des deux frères décrits
comme alcoolique et violent mais dans la
salle c'est un tout autre discours que
les jurés vont entendre les témoins ont
dépin des jeunes gens plutôt
sympathiques plutôt agréable et qui
n'avait pas un comportement particulier
ni avant ni après les faits alors
c'était même curieux parce qu'on
s'attendait à des témoignages à charge
vu la réputation qu'ils avaient on a vu
des gens qui qui disaient que c'était il
travaillent bien qu'ils étaient plutôt
d'agréable
compagnie lors de l'évocation des faits
un expert va ensuite venir semer un
doute dans la salle
d'audience car pour l'accusation les
deux frères auraient commis le meurtre
ensemble Johann tenant sa mère par le
coup pendant que Aurélien l'a frappé à
mort la théorie sur le fait qu'il a deux
agresseurs en même temps manifestement
ne tient pas de bout parce que les cous
sont du une violence extrême ça c'est
c'est absolument indéniable quelqu'un
qui mettrait son sa main au niveau du
coup de la victime pendant que l'autre
frappe et notamment au niveau de la
mâchoire se prendrait des coups sur la
main d'une façon à peu près certaine et
d'autre part la personne qui
maintiendrait le corps serait maculé de
sang or malgré les examens poussés des
enquêteurs aucune trace de sang n'a été
retrouvée ni sur Johann ni sur Aurélien
aujourd'hui
dans la salle l'accusation apparaît de
plus en plus fragile et c'est lors de
l'évocation des aveux de Johan que le
procès va vivre un incroyable
rebondissement en fait Joan Toinon
raconte à la barre que c'est sous la
pression des gendarmes qu'il a accusé
son frère
Aurélien alors chose rare le président
va demander à vérifier comment s déroulé
la garde à vue pour crever l'absès on
décide
de visionner les gardes à
vu c'est pendant sa 4e audition que
Johann met en cause Aurélien les jurés
et la cour l'entendent déclarer avoir vu
la voiture de son frère quitter la
maison le matin du
drame puis à la 5e audition le jeune
homme se rétracte
totalement alors les gendarmes coupent
la caméra afin de faire une pause de 30
minutes la demiheure scoule et qu'on
passe donc la 6e audition et on entend
le gendarme dire comme vous venez de me
le dire précédemment vous conscenté à
vous expliquer sur ce qui s'est
réellement
passé ce matinlà comme si de rien nétait
Johan reprend la parole et accuse à
nouveau son frère mais dans la salle
d'audience les jurés qui regardent la
vidéo voit bien que l'attitude de Joan a
changé on a l'impression et ça les jurés
vu qu'il récite un texte qu'il fait que
répéter ce qu'on lui dit on voit bien
qu'il n'y a aucune
spontanéité et là je crois qu'on a
touché le
fond fin de la 5e audition il se passe
rien il y a la pause d'une demi-heure de
remise en
confiance c'est quoi cette remise en
confiance qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
durant ces 33 minutes de soi-disant
repos monsieur Joan Toinon n'est pas
retourné dans sa cellule pour se reposer
ce qui est normalement une obligation
légale et un enquêteur a expliqué que
c'était une un travail de remise en
confiance que ces 33 minutes c'était une
sorte d'audition off dans son box Johan
raconte à la cour que pendant cette
pause les gendarmes lui auraient dit
qu'il ne pouvait plus se rétracter en
manque d'antidépresseur le jeune homme
aurait finalement craqué on était filmé
après quand il sarrê de filmé il nous
disait ce qu'il fallait qu'on dise et
puis dès qu'il refilma on disait ce
qu'il voulait entendre après avoir
visionné ses bandes un énorme malaise
s'installe dans la salle les aveux de
Johann l'unique élément à charge du
dossier viennent de s'effondrer je crois
que ces auditions auront eu un effet
assez particulier sur les sur les jurés
et sur le public qui avait l'air quand
même assez choqué des conditions de
cette garde à vue il voit ça comme comme
comme il ver un film enfin je je pense
qu'il n'imagine pas que la garde à vue
peut être aussi difficile à vivre et
qu'il y a ce genre de pression qui
puisse encore exister quand on n pas de
mobile quand on n pas euh d'éléments
matériels euh quand on a rien dans un
dossier des aveux aussi peu
circonstanciés à l'arrivée à la fin de
la garde à vue à 48h ça vaut
rien après 6 jours d'audience
l'accusation ne tient plus qu'à un fil
l'avocat général requiierent tout de
même une peine de 15 à 20 ans contre les
deux frères évidemment les avocats de la
défense eux plaide l'acquittement il y a
absolument aucun élément dans cette
procédure qui permette de penser qu'ilst
qu'ils ont tué le mère après 4h de
délibérer les jurés rendent leur verdict
la cour est
revenue donner le verdict prendre le
verdict et on a eu un verdict
d'acquitement moi qui suis quelqu'un de
très renfermé je montre pas mon
émotion là les larmes sont sorties oui
je me suis effondré oui j'ai même
presque fait un petit malaise on va dire
mes jambes se sont coupées je me suis
assis et je me suis vraiment effondré en
larme l'émotion qu'il a la
barre ça résume tout ce qu'il a pu vivre
et je crois que c'est le
meilleur témoin de son innocence ah voà
c'est
soulagement soulagement ah
oui ah le bonheur là
ah oui ah mon c le bonheur ah c le
bonheur quand j'ai entendu le monom
coupable C l'uporie ils ont étéquit
parce que personne n'a cru leur
culpabilité d'abord pour commencer ils
ont été acquités parce que en face que
ce soit l'accusation ou l'enquête on n
pas établi on n pas amené suffisamment
d'éléments pour prouver leur
culpabilité le parquet a fait appel de
ce jugement et un nouveau procès se
tiendra
prochainement la famille Toinon est
aujourd'hui déchirée les trois plus
jeunes enfants n'ont plus aucun contact
avec leur père à l'heure qu'il est la
mort d'anit Toinon reste un mystère
c'est un énorme point d'interrogation et
et tous les gens disent mais qui a tué
anit
[Musique]
Toinon